another day is breaking on the Isle of
Man a peaceful Retreat for Michelle moan
a self-made darling of the British
business Community who is now fighting
allegations that she used her position
to profit from government PPE contracts
moan a conservative peer has stepped
back from the House of Lords to clear
her name but she has been noticeably
quiet so far
I'm here at Michelle Moon's house on the
Isle of Man
I'm going to try and see if anyone's in
I'm I'm here from Sky News it is
Michelle moaning
she's unavailable do you think she might
be around later for a chat
all right all right thanks
I'm trying my best
but I don't get the sense I'm going to
have much luck here
okay
is there any way you could ask inside
for us if she's in we just want to have
a chat I'm sure you do
foreign
there goes another one we've been here
for about half an hour now people have
been coming and going initially we
weren't sure whether Michelle moon was
going to be in but there are signs of
life here the wreaths are up the
Christmas trees are up the lights are
coming on so it looks like the
festivities are very much still on here
but nobody here is willing to have a
chat with us
moan has gone quiet now
but at the height of the pandemic she
was pressuring the then Health secretary
Matt Hancock to award PPE contracts to a
company that was later revealed to be
connected to her husband Douglas
Barrowman I'm going to blow this all
wide open a smell of rat here it's more
than the usual red tape incompetence and
bureaucracy that's expected I believe
there is corruption here at the highest
levels under cover-up is taking place
don't say I didn't Warden you when
Panorama or Horizon run an expose
documentary and all this
I see a Level Playing Field for all
the company in question PP medpro its
owner Anthony page is an employee of
Michelle's husband Douglas
hello are you Anthony can we have a chat
from Sky News
usually spreads quickly on the Isle of
Man but there's a sense of resignation
about these Revelations a feeling that
this is just another Westminster scandal
look at uh Boris and Matt and all them
and then they're all telling feds at the
end there it doesn't matter who they are
or what their status is in life I think
people needs to be
um accountable for whatever they do
whether it is public in the public eye
or with government but when the world is
in crisis and somebody's financially
gaining from it it's just there's no
words as though it's a shocking unless
you've got the full facts and the
figures you're making judgment on
someone without actually knowing the
full story
um it's a shame when whenever someone
doesn't act in the way that you would
wish all politicians to act
people here are hardly impressed by what
they're hearing about Michelle Moon
but a lot of residents here either
aren't affected by the news they're not
interested or they're reticent about
speaking Michelle moan denies all
allegations but the House of Lords is
looking into whether she broke any rules
and criminal investigation into PPE Med
Pro is underway
for now however Michelle moan has pulled
up the drawbridge
Sky News Isle of Man